we often hear people say i want to be
successful and i'm sure you might have
said this to yourself as well when you
hear the word success what does it mean
to you to some being successful means
having a lot of wealth to others it may
be overcoming a fear and still to others
it simply means having good health and
happiness in life
success is something that you have to
define for yourself and no one can do it
for you and the meaning of success will
keep changing in our lives when we were
still a student success simply meant
scoring good grades in our exams but
that changes as we become an adult and
start working success could mean having
a good job earning a good salary and
making an impact in the society but as
we get into our golden age success could
simply meet having good health and being
truly happy no matter where we're at in
our lives the one thing everyone's
definition of success has in common is
achieving some sort of goal or a purpose
hence no matter how you define success
for yourself the principles of how to be
successful in life remain the same so in
this video i'll be sharing with you
seven ways to build a mindset for
success and happiness
when i was in my early 20s i came across
a book called ikigai and it has honestly
changed the way i lived my life
some of you might have heard of this
concept for some it might be something
new to you
ikigai is a japanese concept that means
your reason for being iki in japanese
means life and gai describes value or
worth so your ikigai is what gives your
life worth meaning and a purpose it is
what brings you joy and inspires you to
get out of bed every day
so how do you find your ikigai
ask yourself these four questions
what do you love what are you good at
what does the world need
what can you get paid for
the center point is a diagram where all
the four circles overlap is your ikigai
it is the point where a number of
aspects come together what you love what
you're good at what the world needs and
what you can get paid for so why is
living your ikigai important in being
successful instead of working in a job
that you hate just for the sake of
paying your bills or on the flip side
blindly following your passion but
you're unable to sustain your life
discovering your ikigai brings balance
to your life it is where your passion
mission craft and calling intersect as a
result your ikigai will give you a
reason to get up every morning it gives
meaning to your life you'll love what
you do you'll contribute more to your
job and those around you you'll be
inspired to keep going and as a result
you'll be successful in whatever goals
you have set yourself
for me my ikigai is doing this
sharing my love knowledge and experience
in health and fitness and helping other
people to be a better version of
themselves
the main culprit that keeps you from
stepping out of your comfort zone and
getting the life of your dreams is your
own inner critic
the moment you try to do something bold
or interesting with your life it slaps
you down with voices that says i'm not
good enough i'm gonna embarrass myself
i've failed way too many times
the inner conversations you have with
yourself can either be a powerful
stepping stone or a major obstacle to
reaching your goals
your thoughts greatly influence how you
feel and behave hence negative self-talk
can become downright self-destructive
telling yourself that you'll never be
successful or that you aren't as good as
others will reduce your feelings of
self-worth and stop you from taking
actions
our negative thoughts are often
exaggerated biased and untrue
so how do we change that firstly start
to become more aware of the
conversations you have with yourself
what are you telling yourself how does
it make you feel is it helping you
towards your goal
once you have an objective view of your
thoughts then you will be able to change
the conversation you're having with
yourself whenever i'm feeling anxious or
when i start to have self-doubt i will
always talk to myself joanna you can do
this joanna you got this as crazy as it
sounds it has always helped me to take
that leap of faith and work on becoming
better and of course remember to
celebrate your progress at small
victories along the way as you work
towards your goal because that's how you
become successful
i'm sure you've heard this thing many
times if you don't have a plan then you
plan to fail while this may be true it
is only a small part of the equation to
success i'm sure we all have friends who
always have big plans to do this big
project or to start a new business or to
try something different in their lives
however few years down the road they are
still exactly where they were a few
years ago it is just a lot of talk
without action while having a clear plan
is extremely important for success
most people tend to stop right there
even though you can have the best plan
written down you won't know how it would
turn out until you start doing it and
one of the most common reasons why
people don't take action is because
they're afraid of failing so instead
they start giving themselves excuses to
just keep planning and to make it better
until they are ready
but the truth is you will never be fully
ready the thing that often separates
successful people from unsuccessful
people is simply taking action
those who achieve success may not be
smarter than those who don't but they
make a plan they have a timeline and
they stick to it as soon as they feel
motivated or a strong emotion towards
something
they take immediate action that doesn't
mean that they will succeed in fact they
might fail but that's how they learn
improve and get better until they
succeed
setbacks are necessary lessons and steps
towards success if you are just stuck in
the planning phase then you will never
get closer to your goals so stop
planning and start doing
if you want to be successful in life you
must have a growth mindset and take on
the role of being a lifelong learner the
truth is you wouldn't achieve success
overnight you have to take consistent
action test various ideas fail
get back up and see your growth if you
aren't in a growth mindset you probably
have a fixed mindset which stops you
from achieving things in your life a
fixed mindset is when you believe your
basic qualities intelligence talents and
abilities are just fixed traits and they
cannot be improved or this is the way i
am or i am not taught to do this or i
can't do this with a growth mindset you
believe that your talents and abilities
can be developed over time through
experience and mentorship and you'll
push yourself and go for it people with
a growth mindset aren't worried about
how smart they are or how they will look
if they make a mistake they will always
challenge themselves and keep growing
hence maintaining this growth mindset
allows you to take every opportunity to
be a better employee student spouse
parent or whatever you set your mind to
be remember success never happens in one
day but if you continue to improve
yourself every day you will be
successful
when you observe successful people most
of them are fit and healthy why is that
so
besides the known benefits of exercising
which includes more energy better mood
and lower stress levels having a regular
fitness routine also teaches you
discipline focus resilience and to excel
beyond your limits that is one of the
best things about exercise it puts your
mind in contact with your body and makes
them whole hence working hard and
working out go hand in hand
so start prioritizing your body and set
a regular exercise routine give your
body the attention it deserves and
believe me you'll see improvements in
all areas of your life
you might start off living your job
loving your role as a parent and loving
what you do
but if we just keep going and going
without taking breaks eventually you
will get burnt out and that's when
you'll start to feel like you've lost
the passion in what you used to love
doing or you have lost your purpose of
being in life i personally have
experienced this many times and
questioned myself why am i doing what
i'm doing why do i not enjoy it as much
as i used to i'm in the health industry
producing fitness content but i don't
even have the time for myself to work
out i identify so strongly with my work
that i lack the balance between my work
life and my personal life i feel the
need to push myself to work harder and
eventually burn out these experiences
has taught me that i needed to take
necessary breaks if i want to continue
to do what i do in the long term if i
can't even help myself and be inspired
how can i reach out to others
i've learned that it is okay to take a
step back and slow down it is okay to
say no it is okay to not always be on
top of everything it is almost 10 years
since i started sharing fitness content
online and i can say that i still love
what i do and enjoy speaking to all of
you success is also about being able to
sustain what you do long term in a
healthy manner physically and mentally
so if you're experiencing mental fatigue
take the time to rest and rejuvenate
your mind it will help you to be a
better person and excel further in all
areas of your life
do one slow activity every day for
example slow down your lunch and eat in
peace take a walk through a green area
or
read your favorite book 15 minutes every
night make slow living a small part of
your everyday
and the final mindset for success is
gratitude gratitude is a choice not a
result i'm sure you have heard this many
times it's so easy to be grateful when
you've made it to the top it's easy to
be grateful when you have your career
mission relationships and finances all
going exceptionally well yes that is
true but contrary to popular belief it
is also easy to be grateful during your
struggles or when you're trying to make
improvements and progress in all aspects
of life in fact gratitude is the key
factor in achieving ultimate success and
happiness when you feel happy you feel
optimistic and energized this motivated
energy leads to action and action is the
vital ingredient to your success
studies have shown that people who have
written down what they were grateful for
on a weekly basis were more cheerful and
optimistic about the upcoming week than
those who didn't so one thing that i've
been doing for the past decade is to
keep a grateful journal it is not about
being grateful for all the big things in
life but those small moments we often
overlook by having a grateful journal
and writing it down on a daily or weekly
basis it reminds me of all the good
things i have going on in my life
the more you can be appreciative for
what you have the more you will operate
out of pressure to expand versus fear of
not having enough as a result gratitude
increases confidence and decreases
insecurity gratitude helps you stay
focused on your work and business goals
and you're less likely to be distracted
by worries gratitude makes you a more
effective manager business owner parent
or student
gratitude makes everything better your
success ultimately comes down to your
actions perceptions and attitudes having
a goal is half the battle you need to
have a plan and take action i hope this
video will help you to start applying
these 7 principles and achieve what you
believe is the epitome of success
if you want more mindset videos then do
let me know what other topics should i
cover in the comments below and don't
forget to hit the subscribe button if
you haven't yet done it and check out my
other videos on my youtube channel and i
will see you next time all the best